le djihadiste salam Abdeslam ne rentrera
pas en France pour purger sa peine de
prison à perpétuité jusqu'à nouvel ordre
hier mardi 3 octobre la cour d'appel de
Bruxelles a temporairement suspendu le
transfert vers l'Hexagone du dernier
terroriste vivant ayant participé aux
attentats du 13 novembre 2015 la raison
invoquée un risque de violation des
articles 3 et 8 de la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme car si
les remis aux autorités françaises le
djihadiste devra purger la peine de
prison à perpétuité incompressible à
laquelle la cour d'assis spécial de
Paris avait condamné en juin 2022 or
cette peine qui rend infime tout espoir
de libération pourrait constituer un
traitement inhumain ou dégradant en
violation de l'article 3 de la
Convention autre argument l'obligation
de respecter la vie privée et familiale
du condamné en Belgique Salah Abdeslam
pourrait recevoir la visite de ses
proches et bénéficier de meilleures
conditions en vue de sa re socialisation
on fait valoir ses avocats c'est
désormais le tribunal de Bruxelles qui
devra se prononcer sur son extradition
ou non vers la France une procédure qui
pourrait durer plusieurs mois voire
année depuis son arrestation en mars
2016 Salah Abdeslam 34 ans a effectué la
plus grande partie de sa détention en
France mais il a fait l'objet d'une
remise temporaire à la Belgique en
juillet 2022 pour y être jugé cette fois
pour les attentats de mars 2016 à
Bruxelles perpétré par la même cellule
djihadiste s'il reste en Belgique Salah
Abdeslam n'aurait à purger qu'une peine
à perpétuité simple la perpétuité
incompressible n'étant pas en vigueur
dans le pays